when interpreting
pay attention to so what i'm going to
give you first is
a positive list some good things to pay
attention to and then sort of like a
negative list some things you have to be
very careful for i'm going to give you
some examples okay what do you see
what's the first thing
okay why is the title important
yeah otherwise it's like this could be
about anything right you've got lots of
numbers you've got lots of trends but
what is this actually explaining to you
okay
secondly and we don't have to put the
whole thing there but you can see
there's the
after the title
there's like the vertical part which
measures something and the horizontal
part which measures something what's our
name for that starts with an a you can
see it there
the
the axes very good so the axes they
ought to be labeled again just like the
title to describe what is going on
number three is really
tricky number three says what's the word
scale so when you hear the word scale
what does that mean to you if you could
come up with like some person has never
met the word scale before and how would
you explain it
um like how much the numbers should go
off by very good how much the number
should go up by on every part as you go
up the graph and also
to the right as you increase or decrease
as it goes by
i'm going to leave the other three that
are there there are things for you to
continue thinking about now as you note
these i want to point out some examples
of where you have to be careful okay
i've got some pictures and we're going
to have to think about them together so
here's one
now here's a graph it's got some things
that are useful and it's got some things
that are not so useful what's the title
vote line there it is in big so you know
this is something to do with voting you
know a political sort of thing right
okay now some of you are smiling because
you've realized wait wait a second okay
i guess sort of a sub question uh
subtitle rather is today's question it
says do you like the plan to remove the
car lane
actually now take that back it's this
one this is um oh is it no i'm not sure
this is the result right now just have a
look at the graph for a minute have a
look at it what's wrong with this graph
because there's like kind of something
really big wrong with this graph merrick
what do you see
right now we're so wired we see yes as
green right and then you see this green
thing over here you're like oh those are
the same which i think they are intended
to be the same and then you see red
that's no and then this other red thing
but the numbers are completely backwards
aren't they right now
when you're flicking through a newspaper
the last time you picked up a newspaper
or if you're like flicking through a
social media feed or something like that
right
how closely do you think you have a look
at these little details
probably not very at all you're just
kind of skimming past right so these are
really tricky and in fact these come up
i would have shown you more examples but
then we would spend the whole lesson
just looking at examples of this okay
have a look at this for a second this is
from um this is from the uk this is the
uk have a look at it right
last week we asked whether a levels
these are like advanced exams in the uk
whether they're becoming harder to pass
and you said
well apparently
number one
50 said yes 49 said no
where's the one percent there's another
question okay so we're missing some
people and then the other problem is the
same thing we observed in the previous
chart what's the other problem
yeah it's it's smaller
it's not even close to what should be
half right okay so you can see what
we're looking at is examples of
misleading graphs or statistics let's
have a look at this one
this one you have to think a little more
carefully about these things i asked you
to pay attention to look closely
have a look at our list we only wrote
down three things what's the first thing
that's missing
there's no title so you kind of have to
which is part of why you're staring at
it thinking wait what does this mean
okay now for those of you who haven't
encountered the word fiscal before this
is about money it's like financial
details that kind of thing you have to
kind of turn your head sideways a little
bit and there are some acronyms that you
and i both don't know what they stand
for what's an rpg it's a
rocket-propelled grenade what's going on
role-playing game i don't know okay
but there's one other
really really big problem that's the
actual main thing that is misleading
about this not that there's a title not
that there's a term that you don't know
what it is even if you knew what it was
there's another problem what do you see
the shark
the axes what's up with the axes
the numbers okay so that's helpful we
know the numbers there's something up
with those can someone yeah what do you
say there's two different types of
numbers ah okay so when you say two
different right i see numbers down here
what are these
these are years okay so that's fine time
is progressing
there's two different numbers or kinds
of numbers on the vertical scale right
here and here two different scales now
before you all say wait a second that's
ridiculous right i'm going to point out
people do this all the time okay this is
actually a very common way of
representing data and it's the idea of
we're trying to be efficient we're
trying to show you two things that we
want to compare and so we show you them
intentionally with two different scales
but there's a bigger problem right when
you've got these different scales when
you look at just ignore the scales for a
minute look at the blue and the red
graphs just look at those lines
they look like they're pretty like
competing on a fair sort of level ground
right like they're sort of in between
each other sort of one takes the lead
and then the other one takes the lead
and sort of seems like a fair fight
right
now have a look more closely the blue
line follows one scale and the red line
follows another one which one is which
which one is which
ah so it's it's sort of disguises to you
a little bit right the blue one says
non-competing so then you have to look
and say well which scale is that i think
that's this one here do you see that
okay so in other words the blue lines
they range from 2 650 up to 3 050.
that's the blue lines they're all going
on this scale
then the red lines are 750
to
1150. so in other words the highest of
the red numbers
is less than half
of the lowest of the blue numbers does
that make sense if you could redraw this
graph and it actually had the same scale
on both then very very roughly where did
my red go
it's disappeared here it is
if we could draw these because those red
numbers are all so much lower right
you're going to have actually your red
numbers down here and then your blue
numbers where are they going to be
way up they're going to be all there's
not even a competition between these
things right there's one other thing and
i didn't put it on here but it is on
your list there i think it might be
number four is it number four it is it
is number four i keep on misplacing my
markers um is the origin origin
origin what does that mean
very good it's where does this graph
begin and you can see see how these
numbers they go wildly up and down they
sort of vary very highly but part of
reason why is because actually the
variation is all between these numbers
if we started from zero
these numbers would only wiggle about
just a little bit okay all right one
last one just to show you and then
you're going to have a go at these
yourself
so this is a different kind of tricky
misleading graph
uh does it have a title
it does just barely
trash okay so at least it tells us what
it's about um does it have a helpful
scale is there anything confusing about
the scale
interesting okay so for starters at
least we don't have two scales to worry
about the origin you can see are there
any issues with the origin
it starts at zero that's helpful okay
and just like in the previous graph
we've got time passing down the bottom
the issue is not to do a scale it's not
to do with the origin it's not to do
with the time what is the issue what do
you reckon
you don't know what the
yeah the actions are showing so we've
all kind of inferred that this is time
because of the numbers but you're like
150
150
what 150 uh
bins 150 tons 100 feet who knows right
so there's the first issue no axes that
are labeled that's why patients do what
else anush
pictures
yeah very good these pictures right
these pictures are two-dimensional
aren't they right they grow in size
horizontally and vertically but this
vertical these horizontal lines across
here they're all about these values and
so see this how much bigger how much
bigger does this trashcan look compared
to this one
like huge right yeah i'd say eight to
ten times bigger now have a look at the
vertical scale
how much bigger is it actually than the
first one what do you see haley
bigger by 150 so this one's 100 right
this one's bigger by 150 so a little bit
over double
but that does not look double the size
of this as we said before i think you
could fit eight or ten of these in here
so that's misleading in a different way
and just like the very first graph as
you're sort of just scanning on through
our eyes tweak to this and we get
tricked if we're not paying close
attention does this make sense